je me souviens très bien une des
premières fois que je suis sortie avec
lui s'il ya grosso modo 10 ans j'ai
croisé un autre propriétaire de chien
qui m'a demandé le prénom du mien j'ai
répondu à aristote mellal autres
propriétés radi a comme le mari de
jacqueline kennedy en fait il voulait
parler d'aristote onassis
c'était d'un milliardaire grec avec
lequel la femme du président américain
john fitzgerald kennedy s'était remarié
après le fameux et assassinats de 1963
la remarque du propriétaire de chien m'a
comme a paralysé sur le moment j'ai eu
la flemme de commencer une explication
et j'avais envie de répondre non c'est
pas lui le grand aristote
[Musique]
legrand aristote n'est pas un
milliardaire du 20e siècle mais un
philosophe du ivème siècle avant
jésus-christ et pas n'importe quel
philosophe grec il est le dernier des
trois plus grands noms de la pensée de
la grèce antique socrates qui a été le
maître de platon lequel a été le maître
d'aristote comme pour platon à propos
duquel j'ai déjà publié une vidéo il y a
peu de sources fiables sur la vie
d'aristote et il ya encore moins
d'informations la principale source ce
sont les villes doctrine illustre de
diogène laërce livre qui est la
référence pour les biographies des
penseurs de l'antiquité encore une fois
ce n'est pas une biographie de 800 pages
sur la vie d'aristote mais le peu de
choses qu'on apprend sont très
intéressantes non seulement aristote a
eu un destin exceptionnel mais vous
allez voir que ce destin nous permet de
comprendre beaucoup de choses sur la
manière dont le monde fonctionne encore
aujourd'hui je vais donc partager avec
vous dise anecdote étonnante est
révélatrice sur la vie d'aristote vous
allez voir qu'elle est la toute dernière
est particulièrement surprenante elle
concerne le lien mystérieux entre la
mort d'aristote et celle de socrate 77
ans plus tôt
on pense à la xénophobie on imagine
spontanément que ce sont des individus
d'autres continents d'autres
civilisations qui en sont victimes et
bien dans les préjugés ne compte pas les
kilomètres
l'être humain est un animal tribal donc
il est capable d'être raciste avec
l'habitant du village d'à côté et
aristote en a fait l'expérience
contrairement aux deux autres géants de
la pensée grecque se crac et platon
aristote n'est pas née à athènes il est
originaire de stage here un village au
nord-est de la grèce actuelle c'est une
très vieille colonies ionienne qui avait
été l'allié d'athènes dont elle est
distante de seulement 500 km en quoi
cette anecdote est elle révélatrice et
bien aristote est ce qu'on appelle un
[ __ ] à athènes ce terme français mais
tech vient du grec metal quo ce qui
signifie étrangers et son origine
aristote ne peut pas la faire oublier
quand il vient vivre à athènes à 17 18
ans il est surnommé le stage irrite et
les athéniens se méfie de lui vingt ans
plus tard à la mort de platon aristote
appareils comme son successeur naturel
en effet malgré leurs désaccords
intellectuelle aristote était le
disciple préféré le principal assistant
et platon l'appeler même l'intelligence
de l'école mais voilà l'académie ne peut
pas être dirigé par un [ __ ]
on oublie souvent une chose quand on
parle de philosophie on ne peut pas
philosopher c'est poser et réfléchir
librement s'il frigo est vide et oui il
y à bien une hiérarchie des besoins
comme l'expliquent la fameuse pyramide
de maslow donc se consacrer à la
philosophie c'est un privilège ça m'a
frappé en lisant les biographies des
philosophes de l'antiquité de diogène
laërce ce sont tous des fils de bonne
famille d'aristocrates de grands
propriétaires terriens ou de riches
marchands le schéma qui revient souvent
c'est qu'il décide d'intégrer une école
philosophique à l'adolescence tous frais
payés par la famille alors bien sûr il
ya des exceptions socrates étant la plus
célèbre mais ce sont des exceptions
aristote lui ne fait pas exception il
est le fils d'un médecin qui est l'ami
personnel en plus d'en être le médecin
du roi de macédoine à main tu as trois
de macédoine le grand père d'alexandre
le grand en clair aristote nez avec les
trois capitaux au sens de bourdieu il a
le capital économique puisque sa famille
elle vit dans l'aisance financière il a
le capital social à puisque le père
d'aristote à un puissant réseau
politique à travers son amitié avec le
roi de macédoine enfin aristote a aussi
le capital culturel car son père l'élève
dans l'atmosphère de la médecine
d'ailleurs la mer et sages femmes comme
celle du socrates et aristote baigne
plus largement dans la science au cours
de son enfance d'ailleurs c'est
certainement cette éducation qui
explique l'originalité de l'esprit
d'aristote son ouverture sa rigueur
empirique et même son pragmatisme je
trouve certains biographes disent qu'il
est médecin comme son père et qu'il
prescrit des remèdes à ses connaissances
une légende fait même de lui le petit
fils d'asclépios le dieu de la médecine
ils passent énormément de temps sur des
îles en dehors d'athènes a collecté des
échantillons pour étudier les animaux et
les plantes il théorise le
fonctionnement de vie au point que
certains font de lui le fondateur de la
biologie
quand on pense à un philosophe on
n'imagine pas un bodybuilder ni même un
guerrier on se dit qu'un philosophe
dévalorise le corps puisque il valorise
l'esprit et qu il dévalorise la violence
physique puisqu'ils valorisait la
réflexion et le dialogue alors ce n'est
pas toujours vrai par exemple socrate et
platon étaient tous les deux des hommes
forts particulièrement platon et ils se
sont illustrés à la guerre le courage sa
crainte est légendaire aristote lui
colle bien mieux à l'image qu'on se fait
d'un philosophe il est assez faible
physiquement il est petit il a des
jambes très maigre la voix faible et de
petits yeux contrairement à socrate dont
les grands yeux fascinés ses
interlocuteurs que tirer de l'apparence
physique d'aristote et bien aristote
n'est pas comme platon un homme qui en
impose par son physique il n'est pas non
plus un homme charismatique comme
socrate donc on ne le remarque pas
spontanément
marquer si on n'est pas à grands pas
costaud et qu'on n'est pas non plus
charismatique alors vous allez peut-être
envie de me dire aristote est super
intelligent ça suffit pour se faire
remarquer oui mais l'intelligence ça
n'est pas instantané ça ne capte pas
l'attention comme la taille la
musculature où le charisme donc aristote
compense sa faiblesse physique et son
absence de charisme par le style au
point que les gens de l'époque le lui
reproche il est toujours vêtu avec
recherche ils portent des bagues et des
anneaux il a les cheveux courts et ils
se rasent ça le fait vraiment sortir du
lot parce que la barbe est un symbole de
virilité et de sagesse dans la grèce
antique on peut même aller en prison
pour avoir coupé la barbe d'un autre
homme en quoi cette anecdote est elle
révélatrice et bien à la révèle
qu'aristote contrairement à beaucoup de
philosophes de l'époque platon le
premier aristote n'est pas un ascète
c'est à dire qu'il ne cherche pas à
faire des efforts héroïques de
discipline pour acquérir la force et la
fermeté du caractère il ne cherche pas à
supprimer le désirant lui il ne
s'inflige pas des souffrances d'ailleurs
on le lui reproche de ne pas incarner la
figure de philosophes qui est au dessus
des plaisirs de la vie matérielle il
collectionnerait la vaisselle c'est
qu'ils seraient preuve de sa gourmandise
il adore revêt lé bain d'huile ce qui
serait preuve de sa mollesse et ils
revendrait même l'huile utilisée pour
ces bains ce qui serait preuve de son
avarice je sais que ça se fait de nos
jours mais j'ai du mal à croire car il
se faisait ça après si on met de côté
les caricatures son mode de vie est tout
de même conforme à sa théorie de la
sagesse parce qu'en effet pour aristote
la sagesse ça consiste à conserver la
juste mesure dans les passions et les
actions tout homme instruit et
raisonnable ne cherche que le juste
milieu écrit-il dans son éthique à
nicomaque
thueux j'ai donné beaucoup de cours de
culture générale et du coup quand j'ai
terminé mes études j'ai eu l'idée de
créer une entreprise qui met en relation
des adolescents avec des étudiants pour
qu'ils les accompagnent et les guide
dans le développement de leur culture
générale l'idée c'était que l'étudiant
joue un peu le rôle d'un grand frère
briand qui stimulent l'intérêt est
l'ambition de l'adolescent et qu'ils lui
fassent gagner en maturité et cette
entreprise je l'avais baptisé aristote
et alexandre pourquoi ce nom par ce
qu'aristote a été le précepteur du
légendaire conquérant alexandre le grand
quand aristote à 41 ans le roi philippe
ii de macédoine le fait venir pour qu'il
s'occupe de l'éducation de son fils de
13 ans alexandre pendant deux ans
aristote lui enseigne tout ce qu'il sait
et à l'époque il est déjà une véritable
encyclopédie vivante mais la relation
dépassait largement du cadre de
l'enseignement aristote devient un ami
et même plus un second père pour le
jeune alexandre l'un lui a donné la vie
l'autre lui a appris à vivre dit plus
tard que dans sa biographie d'alexandre
à propos de philippe lepers et
d'aristote le précepteur le lien qui
unit aristote et alexandre est si fort
que le philosophe reste encore plusieurs
années auprès de son élève lorsque celui
ci devient région de macédoine à 15 ans
que retenir de cette anecdote est un des
plus célèbres exemple de la relation
entre le savoir et le pouvoir parce que
beaucoup de gens penseront comme le
général de gaulle qu'il n'y aurait pas
eu alexandre le grand sans le grand
aristote la véritable école du
commandement et la culture générale au
fond des victoires d'alexandre on
retrouve toujours aristote écrits de
gold envers l'armée de métier l'idée qu
illustre la relation entre aristote et
alexandre idée que je répète souvent sur
cette chaîne est ailleurs c'est que la
culture générale permet de mieux
comprendre le monde et que mieux
comprendre le monde permet de prendre de
meilleures décisions
c'est une évidence on ne peut pas tout
savoir sur tout ce n'est pas humainement
possible parce qu'il ya trop de domaines
et trop de connaissances pour qu'un seul
homme les maîtrise tout il faudrait à la
limite être capable de télécharger tout
wikipédia dans notre cerveau est encore
aujourd'hui c'est impossible mais dans
l'antiquité certains historiens disait
d'aristote qu'il a été la dernière
personne sur terre à savoir tout ce que
savaient les hommes de son époque alors
c'est peut-être exagéré mais il ya un
fond de vérité aristote est un
exceptionnel et rudy qui s'intéresse à
tous les champs du savoir il est un peu
impolie maths de la renaissance ou en
homme des lumières avant leur plate on
le surnomme le liseur et comme si cela
ne suffisait pas vous comprendre il
appelle la maison d'aristote la demeure
du lecteur en pratique aristote dépense
énormément en livres en même temps
c'était pas 99 centimes sur amazon à
l'époque et il est un des tout premiers
à avoir une bibliothèque dans la grèce
antique en quoi cette anecdote est elle
révélatrice révèle qu'aristote est un
des premiers acteurs emblématiques de
l'encyclopédisme dans la civilisation
occidentale son effort d'érudition
illustre la dimension quantitative du
progrès de la civilisation les
accomplissements matériel aux
intellectuels scientifiques duo
artistique dépend en partie de
l'accumulation progressive des
connaissances au fil du temps les forts
de chaque génération s'ajoutant à celui
de la précédente
à l'âge où l'adolescent américain va à
la high school l'adolescent allemand
august nation l'adolescent français va
au lycée et vous savez d'où vient le mot
lycée du grec lucas y sommes et qui est
le nom du gymnase situé près d'athènes
où enseigne et aristote en français on
dit d'ailleurs le lycée pour désigner
l'école philosophique d'aristote ils le
font dans moins 335 il a alors 49 ans
sur le modèle de l'académie de platon il
ya beaucoup d'étudiants et d'après les
témoignages l'ambiance est plutôt
libérale comme platon aristote enseigne
selon la méthode dite péripatéticienne
il discours dans une galerie du lycée en
se promenant avec ses disciples le fait
d'enseigner en marchant était une
pratique courante chez les intellectuels
de l'époque selon certains biographes
aristote se lève très tôt pour donner
ses cours légende raconte qu'on lui met
une boule de bronze dans sa main au
dessus d'un bassin afin que quand la
boule de bronze tombe de sa main dans le
bassin le bruit le réveil mais selon
d'autres biographe c'est l'après midi
qu'aristote fait court alors c'est le
matin ou l'après midi je vous donne la
réponse dans la prochaine anecdote je
reviens au lycée d'aristote il est
inspiré de l'académie de platon
n'hésitez pas non plus une copie
conforme la principale différence c'est
que le lycée est plus portée sur la
biologie et les sciences naturelles
tandis que platon privilégier la
métaphysique c'est à dire la philosophie
hardcore et la littérature que révèle
cette anecdote à mes yeux elle révèle
qu'aristote est lui aussi animé par un
sentiment de rivalité à l'égard de
platon comme je l'expliqué dans ma vidéo
sur platon le maître platon se sont
menacés lorsqu'il prend la mesure de
l'intelligence et de la puissance de
travail du disciple d'aristote mais le
sentiment est réciproque
le disciple veut surpasser le maître le
fait qu'il soit un des rares disciples à
contester les théories du maître en est
la preuve et le fait qu'ils copient
l'école du maître en est une autre
expliqué que selon certains biographes
ils courent d'aristote ont lieu tôt le
matin mais que selon d'autres ils ont
lieu l'après midi eh bien ce ne sont
probablement pas les mêmes cours je
pense qu'aristote donne ses cours à 0
tehrik tôt le matin et ses cours
exotérique l'après-midi l'ésotérisme du
grec ancien et zoo qui signifie à
l'intérieur les hôtelleries sme est la
propriété d'un savoir que seuls des
initiés peuvent comprendre par exemple
la mécanique quantique est un savoir
ésotérique parce qu'il faut avoir un bon
niveau en physique pour comprendre
l'exotisme du grec ancien exode qui
signifie or de l'exotisme est au
contraire la propriété d'un savoir que
tout le monde peut comprendre par
exemple l'histoire de france est un
savoir exotérique parce que c'est
simplement le récit des événements
considérés comme les plus importants
dans la mémoire collective de la nation
française je reviens à aristote le matin
il s'adresse à une audience restreinte
qui a un bagage intellectuel suffisant
pour comprendre des théories avancées
essentiellement des élèves du lycée
j'imagine l'après midi ils s'adressent à
une plus large audience et son discours
tient probablement de ce qu'on peut
appeler la vulgarisation autre
différence l'après midi il abandonne à
la méthode péripatéticienne il fait son
cours à 6 parce ce n'est pas possible de
parler à une foule en marchant avec m en
quoi cette anecdote est elle révélatrice
je trouve qu'elle est révélatrice de
l'ambition d'aristote il veut jouer sur
les deux tableaux il est certains
théoriciens qui s'adresse à l'élite
intellectuelle de son époque mais il
veut aussi être un vulgarisateur qui
s'adresse à un public plus large même si
lui tient un discours différent
malheureusement nous n'avons que
l'oeuvre ésotérique d'aristote compilées
par ses élèves sous forme de traités
scientifiques nous n'avons pas ces
discours de vulgarisation qui étaient
des dialogues socratiques et pour platon
celle inverse nous n'avons que ces
dialogues pas son oeuvre ésotérique
c'est en voyant aristote passé son temps
à écrire que platon commence à se sentir
menacés effectivement aristote n'a pas
chômé il produit une oeuvre immense qui
constitue une sorte d'encyclopédie de
l'époque il écrit énormément de livres
différents sur plein de sujets à en
croire diogène laërce cela représente 4
145 1270 ligne j'ai un petit tout sur ce
chiffre mais bon puis ça fait quand même
beaucoup non il y a une explication à un
moment aristote ce fait la même
réflexion que tous ceux qui veulent
produire une grande quantité de savoir
ça irait plus vite à plusieurs donc ils
commencent à déléguer il travaille avec
des assistants de recherche des
secrétaires et des [ __ ] et puis ces
élèves ont aussi retranscrit ses cours
ce que révèle cette anecdote c'est
qu'aristote un écrivain du ivème siècle
avant jésus-christ introduit déjà la
division du travail dans la production
du savoir on a l'image du philosophe qui
est seul avec lui-même à lire à
réfléchir et à écrire mais l'oeuvre
d'aristote est un travail d'équipé
à 61 ans aristote fui athènes en disant
je ne laisserai pas deux fois péché
contre la philosophie vous avez compris
aristote fait référence à la mort de
socrate souvenez-vous socrates avait été
condamné à boire un poison après avoir
perdu son fameux procès c'est ça la
première fois qu'on a péché contre la
philosophie selon aristote et il risque
d'y avoir une deuxième fois car aristote
se prend à son tour le même genre de
procès ce qu'on appelle un procès d'un
piété et il sait bien qu'il va servir de
bouc-émissaire l'opinion publique s'il
se laisse faire mais pourquoi lui
pourquoi maintenant et bien alexandre
legrand vient de mourir donc les
athéniens sont très remontés contre la
macédoine à laquelle ils sont soumis
depuis 15 ans et comme aristote a été le
précepteur d'alexandre le grand les
athéniens le voit un peu comme un
traître mais contrairement à ce qu rate
il ne va pas jouer leur jeu ni une ni
deux aristote part en exil avec sa
famille à eb une île près d'athènes il
meurt de vieillesse disent les
biographes dans la première année de sa
fuite il n'a que 62 ans qui n'est pas si
vieux mais c'est vrai qu'on ne coule pas
de vieux jours paisibles en fuyant la
persécution
en quoi cette anecdote est elle
révélatrice elle révèle un schéma
récurrent de l'histoire de l'antiquité
grecque la société qui prend un
philosophe comme bouc émissaire aristote
fait référence à socrate mais d'autres
ont subi le même sort c'est par exemple
le cas du précieux cratique anaxagore
qui avait été le premier philosophe à
s'installer à athènes il s'est pris un
procès d'inquiéter parce que son
accusateur estimé que sa théorie
cosmique équivalent est admis et
l'existence des dieux par chance un
hexacore était proche de périclès qui
avait suivi ses cours donc il a eu le
temps de s'exiler comme aristote
aristote n'est pas non plus le dernier à
se prendre ce genre de procès d'autres
philosophes grecs après lui se verront
accusé d'un piété et on peut même se
poser la question ce schéma
concerne-t-il uniquement la société de
l'antiquité grecque ou bien s'est il
perpétue et en occident
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu que vous avez découvert des choses
intéressantes et même inspirante sur
aristote si c'est le cas donné un pouce
bleus à la vidéo et puis laisser un
commentaire pour améliorer le
référencement de la vidéo ce n'est pas
grand chose et puis ça m'aide vraiment
je suis romain j'étais avec mon fidèle
aristote et vous vous étiez sûr mais
l'idée de culture générale rappelez vous
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur
de la pensée j'ai une question à vous
poser vous croyez vraiment que les gens
ont lu tous les livres dont il parle
bien sûr que non sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler grand chose
et oui il y à 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'ya pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq
les étudiants et les personnes les plus
cultivés les profs et les intellectuels
connaissent ces cinq secrets savez vous
avez lu renan comme moi mais il se garde
bien d'en parler les gens qui les
découvrent réussit à développer
rapidement et facilement leur culture
générale parce que leur rapport au
savoir a changé et une fois qu'ils les
appliquent les cinq secrets ils
comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ils savent
s'exprimer avec profondeur sur n'importe
quel sujet ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations c'est dans les
débats et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d'esprit critique ça
vous intéresse et bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets et je vous explique
comment les appliquer dès aujourd'hui
pour vous cultivez 10 fois plus
rapidement sans vous prendre la tête
pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit qu'ils ont sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo croyez moi
faites le et vous me remercierez